(“Aquí se escuchan también los ecos de
quienes anónimamente se han levantado
contra la opresión defendiendo los derechos
humanos exigiendo verdad justicia reparación
y garantía de no repetición”.
+
“Tenemos que abrazarnos como sociedad volver
a querernos volver a sonreír”)
Queridos amigos de VisualPolitik, en los últimos
años, en la política de América Latina
ha destacado un concepto por encima de todos
los demás: la idea del bloqueo legislativo.
Estoy seguro de que no os pilla de nuevas.
Es la nueva tendencia política de la región:
los presidentes llegan al poder, pero sin
controlar los parlamentos.
Por ejemplo, ¿recordáis por qué Guillermo
Lasso convocó elecciones anticipadas?
Efectivamente, lo hizo porque la oposición,
que tenía mayoría en el Congreso, bloqueaba
prácticamente todas las acciones del gobierno.
¿Recordáis qué fue lo que estuvo detrás
del incompetente y desastroso intento de golpe
de Estado de Pedro Castillo en Perú?
Exacto, el Congreso pasaba olímpicamente
del presidente.
En poco más de año y medio, 70 proyectos
de ley enviados por el gobierno fueron completamente
marginados por el Congreso.
Las situaciones de Ecuador y del Perú fueron
extremas, pero en general, el bloqueo político
se ha convertido en una situación convencional
en América Latina.
Es algo que en cierta forma también está
empezando a sufrir Lula en Brasil.
Y en Argentina, de imponerse Milei a Massa
y llegar a la presidencia, es muy probable
que ocurra tres cuartas partes de lo mismo.
Y, eso no es todo, ¿sabéis quién más está
sufriendo esta situación?
Pues nada más y nada menos que el presidente
de la que seguramente haya sido la economía
más próspera de América Latina en los últimos
años.
Os estamos hablando, por supuesto, del chileno
Gabriel BÓRICH] Boric, el protagonista de
este vídeo.
Queridos amigos, un año y medio después
de que Boric asumiera el poder en Chile, muchos
ya dictaron sentencia: su presidencia está
ausente por no decir que para los suyos ha
resultado muy decepcionante.
Claro que, mentiríamos si os dijéramos que
la única razón de su pobre desempeño ha
sido el bloqueo legislativo.
La realidad es que Boric no ha sabido tomar
bien el pulso a Chile, o mejor dicho, a los
chilenos que le dieron su apoyo.
Algo que se ha reflejado perfectamente con
la caída en picado de su aprobación como
presidente:
N1 (Cadem: Aprobación de Boric cae a 28%
y un 86% cree que hay corrupción en caso
Democracia Viva.
Ex-ante)
Y por si fuera poco, Boric también está
sufriendo un paulatino incremento de la criminalidad
en Chile, tal y como ha ocurrido en Ecuador.
Aunque eso sí, a velocidad mucho más lenta…
Al menos por ahora.
Por eso, ante toda esta situación, en VisualPolitik
nos hemos hecho unas cuantas preguntas:
¿Qué expectativas generó Gabriel Boric
con su llegada a la presidencia?
¿Por qué muchos dicen que su mandato está
siendo un completo fracaso?
¿Es realmente así?
¿Cómo está afrontando la creciente inseguridad
que se vive en el país?
Hoy vamos a responder a todas estas preguntas,
pero antes vamos a ver un poco de historia.
[Pero antes dadme solo un segundo, ya que
hablamos de problemas y crisis…
¿Sabíais que nos estamos quedando sin aviones?
O mejor dicho, ¿qué no hay aviones suficientes
y que eso hará subir probablemente los precios
de los billetes?
Os
No es una exageración.
En el mundo no hay aviones suficientes para
atender toda la demanda y los pilotos también
comienzan a escasear.
Esto es algo que está empezando a ser un
problema y que ha obligado a compañía como
Lufthansa a poner de nuevo en marca los A-380
que había retirado.
Pues bien, os cuento todos los detalles en
uno de los últimos vídeos de Si lo Hubiera
Sabido, el canal de información financiera
de Mutuactivos con el que participamos.
Os dejo toda la info y el enlace en la descripción.
Y ahora sí, continuemos.]
T1 ( A LA IZQUIERDA DE LA IZQUIERDA)
A diferencia de Colombia, lo de tener presidencias
de izquierdas no es algo inusual en Chile.
Tras el fin de la dictadura de Pinochet en
1990, Ricardo Lagos y Michelle Bachelet, ambos
líderes de izquierda, ostentaron el poder
desde el año 2000 hasta el 2010 y luego Bachelet
repitió nuevamente en una segunda presidencia
de 2014 a 2018.
Sin embargo, en estos más de 30 años de
democracia, Chile nunca había tenido a un
presidente como Boric, un presidente que presuntamente
iba a situarse mucho más a la izquierda que
los anteriores.
Un paso más allá de lo que podríamos considerar
la socialdemocracia típica.
Pero, ¿cómo consiguió entonces un candidato
como Boric tanto apoyo como para alcanzar
la presidencia en un país como Chile?
Pues bien, para entenderlo tenemos que remontarnos
a 2019, el año del famoso estallido social.
(Tras la grave desaceleración económica
que se produjo al final del mandato de Bachelet
en los años 2016 y 2017, Sebastián Piñera,
que ya había sido presidente de Chile entre
2010 y 2014, consiguió regresar al Palacio
de la Moneda.
causados por un terremoto de escala 8.8 y
afrontar la crisis de los mineros de San José)
Sin embargo, su presidencia no iba a ser nada
fácil.
La crisis que tuvo que enfrentar durante su
primer mandato quedó en nada comparado con
el estallido social que se produjo durante
su segunda presidencia.
En octubre del año 2019, tras anunciarse
un aumento de los precios del transporte público
en la capital, Santiago, se desataron protestas
masivas.
Por supuesto, el precio del transporte fue
solo una excusa.
De repente, decenas y decenas de miles de
chilenos comenzaron a protestar contra la
excesiva desigualdad social que en su opinión
existía en el país.)
Y eso que Chile había hecho grandes avances
reduciendo la desigualdad.
Fijaos.
El país no solo experimentó una importante
reducción de la desigualdad hasta el 2019,
sino que incluso la población que se encontraba
bajo la línea de pobreza cayó de en torno
a un 40% en 1999 a un 9% en 2018.
Da igual, a pesar de los datos y la clara
mejora de las condiciones de vida que estos
reflejaban, una buena parte de la población
chilena tenía una percepción totalmente
diferente.
Lo que contribuyó a que las protestas se
generalizaran y terminarán convirtiéndose
prácticamente en un levantamiento civil.
No obstante, al final el presidente Piñera
logró calmar las aguas, cediendo el principal
reclamo de los manifestantes:
N2 (23/12/2019: El presidente de Chile firma
la ley para un referéndum constitucional
tras más de dos meses de protestas.
RTVE)
Pero por mucho que cediera con este tema,
la realidad es que la aprobación de Piñera
estaba bajo mínimos, y en cierto modo no
es para menos.
Su papel no gustó a prácticamente nadie.
Unos le culparon por no saber contener la
marea y otros por emplear una fuerza excesiva.
Pensad que, durante las protestas, los Carabineros
se vieron completamente desbordados, lo que,
por ejemplo, terminó provocando actuaciones
más o menos erráticas que se saldaron con
34 manifestantes fallecidos entre octubre
de 2019 y marzo de 2020.
Y fue justo en este contexto de enorme tensión
social, con un gobierno que, además, estaba
implosionando políticamente, cuando nuestro
protagonista de hoy se posicionó como el
principal líder de la izquierda enojada que
alimentaba las protestas:
Boric comenzó entonces a liderar la voz de
la oposición.
(Gabriel Boric, que comenzó su actividad
política como líder estudiantil atacando
duramente a los gobiernos de la reinstaurada
democracia, consiguió en 2014 convertirse
en diputado nacional.
Desde el primer momento, sus tatuajes y mohawks
llamaron la atención de todo el Congreso
y, por supuesto, también de la sociedad chilena.
Y eso no es todo.
Su encuentro con Ricardo Palma Salamanca,
un exparlamentario comunista acusado del asesinato
de Jaime Guzman, uno de los autores de la
Constitución de 1980, también fue tremendamente
polémico.
Pero no fue hasta las protestas de 2019 y
sus duras críticas a las fuerzas del orden
cuando su figura se vio catapultada, lo que
le permitió posicionarse como el principal
candidato de la izquierda en las elecciones
de 2021.
Boric prometió entonces medidas como la revisión
de los acuerdos de libre comercio o la imposición
a todas las empresas, ya fueran públicas
o privadas, de la entrega del 50% de los puestos
directivos a los trabajadores.
Al final, no obstante, se vio obligado a moderar
su programa claramente marxista para poder
vencer al conservador José Antonio Kast en
segunda vuelta, algo que finalmente consiguió
gracias, sobre todo, al voto joven y femenino.)
Pese a todo, cuando Boric asumió el cargo
prometió muchas cosas: la nueva constitución,
una fuerte expansión del tamaño del Estado;
un enorme incremento de impuestos equivalente
al 8% del PIB en dos mandatos, transporte
público gratuito, sanidad universal y gratuita…
Y así podríamos seguir con una larga lista
de compromisos.
Boric parecía querer volver sobre los pasos
de Salvador Allende.
Algo que quedó muy claro en su primer discurso
como presidente.
(VIDEO 2: “Como pronosticara hace casi 50
años Salvador Allende estamos de nuevo compatriotas
abriendo las grandes alamedas por donde pase
el hombre libre, el hombre y la mujer libre
para construir una sociedad mejor.
Seguimos, ¡viva Chile!”)
Ahora la pregunta es, ¿está logrando Boric
materializar alguna de sus grandes promesas?
¿Cómo ha recibido el pueblo chileno la presidencia
de Boric?
Bien, pues veámoslo.
T2 (NOQUEADO EN PRIMERA RONDA)
Como ya os hemos contado al principio del
video, la presidencia de Boric ha estado,
hasta el momento, casi absolutamente bloqueada
por una razón: las matemáticas parlamentarias
no están de su parte.
Y es que veréis, la coalición de gobierno
de Boric, formada por su propia coalición
llamada “Apruebo Dignidad” y la coalición
“Socialismo Democrático” cuentan en total
con 67 diputados.
¿Sabéis con cuántos cuenta la oposición?
Con 70, es decir, 3 más.
¿Y en el Senado?
El panorama es aún peor para el gobierno,
porque aquí la oposición de derecha es aún
más fuerte.
Por eso, el impulso de las reformas que tenía
en mente se le ha complicado y mucho a Boric:
el bloqueo parlamentario prácticamente ha
bloqueado su presidencia.
Y eso está ocurriendo, además, con una oposición
que cada vez es más popular.
El caso es que esta situación ha afectado,
incluso, a la ley más importante de su gobierno:
la reforma tributaria.
(La reforma tributaria presentada por el ministro
de Hacienda de Boric, Mario Marcel, pretendía
aumentar la recaudación en 4.1 puntos del
PIB de manera gradual a lo largo de la legislatura.
Esperaba con ello poder financiar buena parte
de su programa político.
Para conseguir ese objetivo de recaudación
se preveía la creación de varios impuestos.
Por ejemplo, un impuesto a la riqueza con
dos tramos, uno de un 1% y otro de un 1.8%,
que gravaba el ahorro a todos los residentes
en Chile con patrimonios superiores a los
5 millones de dólares.
O también un impuesto a la salida de patrimonios
de un 5% sobre los contribuyentes que cambiaran
su residencia tributaria.
Además, la reforma también incluía mayores
competencias para el Servicio de Impuestos
Internos y la creación de la figura del denunciante
anónimo, que resultaba especialmente problemática
por crear un incentivo monetario para los
denunciantes.)
Y, claro, semejante reforma choca frontalmente
con la posición política de la oposición.
¿El resultado?
Os lo podéis imaginar.
N3 (Chile: rechazo a la reforma tributaria
impacta al Gobierno
A un año del inicio del Gobierno del presidente
de Chile, Gabriel Boric, las esperanzas por
un cambio profundo parecen esfumarse.
La izquierda chilena deberá buscar nuevos
acuerdos con la derecha más moderada.
DW)
Al final, a Boric no le ha quedado otra que
moderar sus planes.
De hecho, este pasado agosto cambió su propuesta
por una que no aumentará excesivamente los
impuestos y que logrará el evar la recaudación
en un punto y medio del PIB a través de ciertas
modificaciones legales.
Sin embargo, y aunque la reforma tributaria
fuera crucial para poder financiar sus grandes
planes, la mayor derrota de Boric, sin duda
alguna, fue la del plebiscito constitucional.
Para quien no lo recuerde, el 4 de julio de
2022 se presentó el proyecto de constitución.
La propuesta nacida del Consejo Constitucional
constaba de 388 artículos, muchísimos para
una constitución.
Pero lo más alarmante de todo no era su extensión,
sino su contenido.
Aquí en VisualPolitik ya os contamos cuáles
eran los principales pilares de ese proyecto:
Dar un mayor poder a los sindicatos, la restricción
excesiva de despido, unos derechos sociales
que no tenían mucho sentido, como el “derecho
universal al deporte”, y medidas que claramente
erosionaban el Estado de Derecho, entre muchas
otras.
Era un proyecto de Constitución muy sesgado
a la izquierda que difícilmente podía representar
a una mayoría de chilenos.
[Y claro, por eso acabó como acabó]
Frente al plebiscito, el Gobierno quiso dar
una imagen de neutralidad, pero la realidad
es que acabó convirtiéndose en la principal
voz a favor del “apruebo”.
Y, ¿sabéis qué significó esto?
Que el plebiscito constitucional también
se convirtió en una especie de referéndum
sobre el gobierno de Boric.
Al final, el 4 de septiembre de 2022 el 62%
de los chilenos rechazaron el proyecto y,
con ello, también en cierta forma la gestión
del presidente.
Pero ¡ojo!
Porque la debacle del liderazgo para Boric
que provocó el proceso constituyente, no
acabaría ahí.
El 7 de mayo de 2023, los chilenos fueron
a votar otra vez, esta vez para reconfigurar
la composición del Consejo Constitucional.
Y, ¿adivináis qué pasó?
Pues…
Fijaos:
N4 (Terremoto político en Chile: la derecha
gana con amplitud las elecciones y tiene en
sus manos la nueva Constitución
El gran triunfador fue José Antonio Kast,
líder del Partido Republicano, que logró
22 de los 50 consejeros.
El Mundo)
Efectivamente, querida comunidad de VisualPolitik,
tras el fracaso del primer referéndum y también
de la reforma tributaria, Boric perdió el
control del Consejo Constitucional frente
al que fuera su contrincante en las elecciones
presidenciales.
El presidente chileno no para de recibir malas
noticias.
No obstante, si alguno está pensando que
su presidencia no podía ir a peor, nada más
lejos de la realidad.
Chile corre el riesgo de experimentar el auge
del mismo fenómeno que ya ha asolado Ecuador
en estos dos últimos años.
Os estamos hablando, por supuesto, de la criminalidad.
Atentos.
T3 (CHILE, LA ÚLTIMA VÍCTIMA DEL CRIMEN)
Seguro, seguro, que todos recordáis el asesinato
en Ecuador del candidato a la presidencia
Fernando Villavicencio.
Os hemos hablado de ello aquí en VisualPolitik.
El asesinato de este candidato es el fiel
reflejo de la terrible deriva que el pequeño
país latinoamericano ha tomado.
Lo más impactante es que, hasta hace solo
un par de años, Ecuador era uno de los países
menos violentos y peligrosos de toda la región.
Pero ahora, sin embargo, se ha convertido
en uno de los más conflictivos y violentos.
Bien, pues esta misma deriva también está
llegando a Chile.
Es cierto, que todavía no ha llegado ni de
lejos a los brutales niveles de Ecuador, pero,
aun así, la deriva es preocupante, muy preocupante.
Por ejemplo, Chile ha sido tradicionalmente
caracterizado por ser un importante país
de origen, tránsito y destino de trata de
personas.
En este sentido, en el país operan extensas
redes sofisticadas que buscan víctimas de
origen asiático, sobre todo de Nepal y la
India, y también de sus vecinos latinoamericanos.
Pero ahora también está tomando mucha fuerza
el tráfico ilegal de armas.
Chile se está convirtiendo en un importante
mercado de compraventa, una actividad que,
incluso, ha salpicado a los propios cuerpos
de seguridad del Estado.
N5 (Militares y carabineros que robaron armas:
sus vínculos con bandas y narcos quedaron
registrados en la justicia militar.
Ciper Chile)
Lo peor de todo es que el aumento del tráfico
ilegal de armas en Chile está fuertemente
relacionado con el narcotráfico en el país.
Y esa es la peor noticia posible.
Aunque pueda sorprenderte, Chile se ha convertido
en un enclave crucial para la droga, especialmente
la cocaína peruana y boliviana, que se traslada
a países tan variopintos como Australia,
Países Bajos o Jordania, entre otros muchos,
a través de importantes puertos como el de
San Antonio.
N6 (Puerto de San Antonio es catalogado mundialmente
por la ONU como principal punto para trasladar
droga.
BioBioChile)
Pues bien, desde 2021 toda esta evolución
ya se está dejando notar con el incremento
de la delincuencia en el país.
De hecho, si nos fijamos en el número de
homicidios y violaciones que tuvieron lugar
en 2022, nos damos cuenta de que hubo un importante
crecimiento respecto a 2021.
Hablamos de una tendencia que no solo no se
está frenando sino que, incluso, podría
estar acelerándose en 2023.
Y eso es lo que explica que en Abril nos encontrásemos
con esta noticia:
N7 (El Parlamento chileno aprueba la ley que
aumenta el poder de la policía en medio de
una crisis de seguridad
La normativa otorga a los agentes más margen
para la legítima defensa y aumenta las penas
para quienes los ataquen.
Gran parte de la nueva izquierda de Boric
le dio la espalda al artículo más controversial.
El País)
Exacto, queridos amigos, el Senado apoyó
de manera unánime la aprobación de la conocida
Ley Naím-Retamal, una ley especialmente polémica
porque consagra la “legítima defensa privilegiada”.
Dicho de otra forma, que le da mayor capacidad
de decisión a los agentes y reduce la rendición
de cuentas de la p olicía.
Además, junto a esta ley, Boric también
aprovechó para impulsar el programa “Calle
sin violencia”, el cual eleva la presencia
de Carabineros en las zonas donde se están
concentrando la mayor parte de los delitos
violentos, pero, por el momento, los cambios
son casi imperceptibles.
Ya lo veis, queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
Boric no ha empezado precisamente con buen
pie.
No ha logrado aprobar su reforma tributaria,
fracasó la opción del “apruebo” que
apoyó su gobierno y perdió las elecciones
al Consejo Constitucional.
La aprobación de su presidencia está en
mínimos históricos, y buena parte de los
chilenos ya le toman como un presidente ausente,
casi desaparecido.
Sí, es cierto, ha logrado impulsar alguna
reforma ante la grave crisis de inseguridad
que atraviesa el país, lo cual por cierto
es rechazado por muchos de sus votantes.
Pero, en general, la mayoría de los analistas
concuerdan en que lo que llevamos de presidencia
de Gabriel Boric, ésta ha sido simplemente
insustancial e irrelevante.
Para muchos su presidencia en cierta forma
ya ha terminado.
Pero claro, eso solo el tiempo podrá o no
confirmarlo, Por ahora queremos saber vuestra
opinión:
¿Debería Boric adelantar elecciones como
hizo Lasso en Ecuador por el bloqueo legislativo?
¿Creéis que logrará llegar a algún acuerdo
parlamentario que le permita finalmente impulsar
sus políticas sociales?
¿Podrán las medidas adoptadas doblegar al
crimen en el país?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Como siempre, no olvidéis que aquí en VisualPolitik
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así
que suscribíos a este canal y dadle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones.
Echadle también un vistazo a Si lo Hubiera
Sabido y, por supuesto, si os ha gustado este
vídeo, dadle a LIKE y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un saludo y hasta pronto.